give public notice that morgan helen
margaret lillian is duly elected as the
member of parliament for the north
shropshire constituency
a sensational by-election victory for
the liberal democrats and a humiliation
for the tories that will increase
pressure on boris johnson from his
mutinous mps the liberal democrats
overturned a 23 000 conservative
majority to win by almost 6 000 votes on
a massive swing of more than 34 per cent
the new mp is chartered accountant and
parish councillor helen morgan
tonight the people of north shropshire
have spoken on behalf of the british
people they've said loudly and clearly
boris johnson the party is over instead
of taking action to help shropshire's
nhs you spend time seeking questionable
no questionable donations to refurbish
your flat
instead of taking action to support
shropshire's farmers you spend your time
misleading the nation on how you and
your office parted during lockdown
by the time ms morgan arrived at the
count the liberal democrats had already
claimed a stunning victory
i think we're not just going to win here
tonight we're going to win comfortably
and the message that's going on from
here tonight is that conservative voters
are tired of being taken for granted
they're tired of being
having a conservative government that
shows them no respect the lib dem leader
sir ed davey who's isolating at home
with kovid couldn't contain his delight
for the conservatives the result is a
disaster in a week when the prime
minister suffered a rebellion by around
100 tory mps over his plan b covid
restrictions it's a difficult moment but
i think it's one that we
can together we can recover from reflect
on what it is that people have told us
and the concerns that they have
the pm's recent woes began with his
bungled attempt to reprieve north
shropshire's previous mp owen patterson
after he was found guilty of breaking
lobbying rules the prime minister's
character and conduct were deliberately
targeted by the liberal democrats during
this by-election campaign
and he is likely to be blamed by
conservative mps for this humiliating
defeat
now after the by-election caused by mr
patterson's resignation the pm's
humiliation has come full circle
and his tory critics will claim he's no
longer a vote winner but a liability
john craig sky news shopshow
well the voters gave us a kicking those
were the words of the conservative party
chairman oliver dowden this morning when
he admitted it was a bad result for the
conservatives
voters in north shropshire were fed up
and they gave us a kicking
and i think they wanted to send us a
message and i want to say as chairman of
the conservative party we've heard that
loud and clear
we need to get on with delivering the
job and that's precisely what we're
doing
well the liberal democrat leader sir ed
davey told us that conservative voters
are dismayed at boris johnson's lack of
decency
i think the people of north shropshire
have sent in a letter of no confidence
in boris johnson to
the conservative 19 1922 committee uh i
i think conservative mps will be very
alarmed by this result uh because these
were lifelong conservatives dismayed at
boris johnson's lack of decency saying
they don't like him they don't want him
and so you know i felt for a long time i
felt that he's not fit to lead our
country and i think more and more people
now who used to trust boris johnson no
longer do